[موسيقى]
ارتفع عدد قتلى تفجير الانتحاري في بيشاور
شمال غرب باكستان الى اكثر من 90
ووقع تفجير في مسجد مجاور للمقر الرئيسي
لقياده الشرطه اثناء تجمع المصلين لاداء
صلاه الظهر رمز
دعا رئيس الحكومه لذي زاره برفقه قائد
الجيش الى التبرعي الدم
ماذا بعد بخصوص اجراءات السلطات
الباكستانيه بعد هذا التفجير
نعم مريم حقيقه ال ال الحصيله ما تزال
ترتفع علمنا قبل لحظات ان الحصيله وصلت
الى 92 قتيلا جراء هذا التفجير الذي كان
قويا لدرجه انه تسبب في انهيار سقف المسجد
الذي تم استهدافه والذي يؤمه عاده عاده
كبير من رجال الشرطه وانا المسجد محاذي
للمقر الرئيسي للقياده لقياده الشرطه في
مدينه بيشاور وفي عموم اقليم خيبر
وبشاور عاصمته بالتاكيد رئيس الحكومه
الباكستانيه الذي زار بالامس همم المصابين
في المستشفى تلقى قبل قليل تقرير او ولي
من عدد من اجهزه الاستخبارات الباكستانيه
التي كانت تحقق بشكل مشترك في همم هذا همم
التفجير حتى الان طبعا لم يتم الكشف عن
فحوى هذا التقرير الاولي لكن من الواضحه
ان هناك ربما بحث الان فيما يتعلق بنوعيه
الماده التفجيريه التي تم استخدامها والتي
تسببت بحسب المعلومات المتوفره لنا حتى
الان في انهيار احد اعمده المسجد ما تسبب
في انهيار سقف المسجد على رؤوس المصلين
التفجير كان قويا لدرجه انه اصاب وقتل عدد
كبير من همم المصلين وايضا تسبب في انهيار
العمود الرئيسي والسقف
لهذا المسجد ما رفع عدد الضحايا وكان
الشخص او المهاجم الانتحاري بحسب ايضا
المعلومات المتوفره الذي نفذ هذا الهجوم
همم كان ربما قد رصد المسجد ورصد المكان
الذي يجب ان يتم وضع فيه هذه العبوه
الناسفه حتى الان ايضا يتم البحث في
الكيفيه التي تمكن من خلالها هذا الشخص
الانتحاري محمد بهذه العبوه
تفجر من الوصول الى هذا المسجد الكثير من
التساؤلات حقيقه الان مطروحه ربما التقرير
الاول اللي اجهزه الاستخبارات الذي وضع
قبل قليل من الان امام رئيس الحكومه ربما
يجيب عن بعض تلك الاسئله لكن بالتاكيد
التحقيقات ما تزال مستمره هناك الكثير من
الجهود التي تبذر حاليا لمحاوله التعرف
على كل التفاصيل المحيطه بهذا التفجير
وايضا لاسيما فن انه ياتي في سياق همم
مسلسل استهداف الرجال الشرطه تحديدا في
اقليم خيبر تحديدا وفي معظم المناطق
المحاضره لافغانستان
جزيلا لك